et tu verras diamant jeune beau du très
jeune beau soucier champ seulement ici
du peuplier votants ils vont tous finir
un petit la merde à lézinnes norbord
west fraser de la serre on fabrique des
panneaux de bois à copeaux un produit
qui se vend des 18 dollars l'an passé
mais pour lequel vous devez maintenant
débourser 60 dollars à la blague
d'environ l'impriment de dollars dans le
genou si l'on apprenne du cas nous on
était dehors avec les marcheurs à
quelques centaines de kilomètres aux
chantiers chibougamau
on fabrique des deux par cas si ces
chocs
demain
donc à chaque fois le jambon à céline
le matériau se détaillait de dollars 60
chez le commerçant en avril 2020 il se
vend aujourd'hui ce dollars 50
les prix ont triplé dans sa forêt au
banc des accusés
les producteurs de bois se défend les
pas de baguette magique peau tout
augmente et la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et ya trois mois il
ya personne qui nous a dit avec nous au
printemps de 8,21
accrochez votre tout comme constructeur
est comme consommateur on va augmenter
de 30% des volumes de consommation par
rapport à avant la commune ont le plus
memorias maïorana pour se préparer une
forte demande qui arrive au moment où
les usines peine encore à rattraper les
semaines de production perdue lors du
confinement du printemps 2020 tous les
ingrédients sont réunis pour semer un
vent de panique chez les acheteurs les
gens à quatre équipes qui sont à la
vente de bois leur téléphone sonne et ce
sont des courtiers en matériaux qui leur
offre un montant x y z qui est
effectivement à la hausse de façon
marquée depuis quelques mois pour
atteindre des sommets absolument
historique
on le reconnaît il ce sont des périodes
très positif pour nous des acheteurs
tout aussi agressif ici que de l'autre
côté de la frontière
près de la moitié de la production de
bois du québec et écoulées aux états
unis
si bien que des voix s'élèvent pour que
le gouvernement adopte une clause québec
qui forcerait les producteurs à
approvisionner le marché québécois en
priorité une solution difficile à
envisager pour l'industrie la vaste
majorité des joueurs comme on respecte
historique de nos clients au déshabille
pages a pour habiller paul
moi je pense qu'on atteint la limite
quant à l'option d'augmenter les volumes
de coupe d'arbres en forêt à court terme
les juges ils seraient incapables de
l'absorber 300 ils peuvent pas avec
toutes les mesures sanitaires et sera
pas capable de produire plus à moi qui
ad'autres lusinchi voir ouvrir ses
portes ce soir
alors que nous réserve l'avenir le
conseil de l'industrie forestière du
québec ne croit pas que les prix
retourneront au niveau de l'an passé et
courtiers en matériaux après alors aux
producteurs un prix tout juste au dessus
du seuil de rentabilité mais les prix
records observés ce printemps ne se
maintiendront pas non plus lorsque la
pandémie
ra contrôle et que le consommateur
retrouvera ses habitudes normal le
conseil s'attend à ce qu'ils
s'établissent à quelque part entre les
deux en attendant le consommateur doit
prendre son mal en patience
dans une région comme l'abitibi
témiscamingue où les usines de
transformation roule à plein régime
il est plus facile de se montrer patient
quant au maintien des activités dans la
plupart des usines à un meilleur retour
sur la ressource que tu exploite pas des
emplois qui sont maintenus à cet
excellent pour la région pour le
consommateur ici valérie gamache
radio-canada la sarre